this is pure anti-Semitism what you just
said the Holocaust to what's happening
today in G you can't make this
up do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad Arad Muhammad Arad has helped
develop all lot of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this
course to access the free lifechanging
training
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends sometimes history repeats itself
in different ways and ironically
sometimes the people who were victim to
atrocities them themselves sadly are
committing this atrocities to a specific
Nation or group of people um there's a
video interview not interview let
interview Sky News with this lady she's
a journalist uh she's a TV anchor she's
uh intervie who she interviewing Zan an
Israeli official called Danon Danon yeah
yeah what a terrible name uh but anyways
so
basically she just mentioned something
but this was this was like it caused
earthquakes I don't understand why
should we watch it for ourselves let's
do it
meas I can guarantee that we will
eradicate Hamas right okay yes yes
absolutely you've doubled down on those
public comments you've called for a
voluntary migration of Palestinians from
Gaza in November you co-authored a piece
that appeared in the Wall Street Journal
you suggested the ethnic cleansing of
some of gaza's population to Western
countries that would accept the refugees
the exact quote from that article one
idea is for countries around the world
to accept limited numbers of G and
families who have expressed a desire to
relocate do you stand by those stat
allow know that's a word you used if you
read my article I spoke about voluntary
immigration I read that article I did
read that let me let me remind you that
you spoke about ethnic cleansing I spoke
about voluntary immigration and I think
anyone in the world who voluntarily
wants to move to another country should
be eligible to do that but you what it's
not the first time that we hear those
allegations I the sort of yes the sort
of voluntary relocation of of many
Jewish people during the Holocaust I
imagine I it is not reloc compare that
shame on you for that comp let us please
a shameful antic equation
please allow to speak about the
hoca this is pure anti-Semitism what you
just said the Holocaust to what's
happening today in G Mr Don you talked
about erting Hamas you for Behavior
shame on you for this equation you
should apologize for what you just said
on on on on record about the Holocaust
how can you even compare that you can't
make this up it's it's impossible if if
if you thought a million years you
cannot make this up why is he so angry
yes what happened in the Holocaust was
atrocious you it was it was catastrophic
everyone in everyone would condemn that
for that matter but why there what's it
called is compart
compartmentalization I don't understand
bro it's a cognitive dissonance what is
it what is it it does not add up to me
bro what's going on it's as if they
decide who's a terrorist they decide
what is a Justified War they decide
what's a holocaust Holocaust they decide
what's a genocide why is he why is he so
angry it's uh it's this high level of
superiority that certain people feel and
you know when certain issues get bought
up they want to put their issues first
and okay a genocide took place and other
genocides have also taken place yes and
in a discussion you should be able to
well in a free speech Society you should
be allowed to compare you should be
allowed to critique y because that's
what free speech is she's a journalist
she's comparing because in her opinion
she feels that there is a comparison
she's Justified it oh no how dare you
you can't say this and then he then opts
and tries to Lobby Sky to get rid of her
labor MP she said something similar that
on Holocaust Memorial Day you should
also remember the gazen genocide and
other genocides as well she got
suspended
she apologized she still got suspended
so certain look other genocides have
taken place you cannot remove this from
the Realms of History yeah you should
remember them but certain people want
you to remember certain atrocities more
than other atrocities all atrocities are
atrocities and should be remembered to
say that one atrocity is you know should
be remembered more this or or you
shouldn't allow any kind of comparison
bro she wasn't even criticizing the
Holocaust she wasn't denying the
Holocaust which Once Upon a Time used to
be a problem but now M even comparing it
m even bringing it into conversation has
become Blasphemous you know Daniel I
think her name is Daniela W or something
like that she was an ex- mayor of one
specific place in Israel she uttered
these words I made a video about this as
well they basically saying a a voluntary
migration what the hell does that mean
she was basically saying we need to have
a humanitarian crisis that these people
have no choice but to leave so their
claim is basically a nutshell that
because the Palestinians are not being
taken by Egypt and Jordan and other
Muslim Arab countries meaning that they
they are problematic people nobody wants
to take them well the same equivalence
can be made to the Jews in in the
Holocaust actually just before the
Holocaust when the iian conference
happened in 1938 with over 32 countries
which were majority European who they
refused to take the Jews now can we make
that com uh comparison and say hold on a
second well are we going to come and say
now the Jews were the problematic people
back then no that'll be anti-Semitism
good this is the point here so why is it
that one rule for the Palestinians and
the Muslims and another rule for the
Jews so this is the issue he because
Palestinians are Hamas sorry they're
Hamas yeah that's right so in the
nutshell guys you can see the freedom of
speech they talk about they live in
utter hypocrisy absolute hypocrisy like
the French philosopher M said they are
strategically consistent not
moralization come on and we can see that
we can indeed is any last words you
would like to say well I'd like to say
that where are the free speech Warriors
now oh they're hiding I haven't haven't
I haven't heard from the far it seems it
seems like the Free Speech Brigade is
hibernating because of all the effort
that they've used and maxed out when it
comes to the Muslims but now when it
comes to you know where it actually
matters Front Page News politicians
coming out and when it comes to Israelis
it's like they've been been given a free
pass you can do absolutely whatever you
want
whenever you want and uh yeah here
you're categorically not allowed to make
comparisons between that and something
else yo you you get fired you lose your
job P Morgan did the same thing a doctor
went on there he ended up losing his job
because of his opinion oh no but it was
a designated terror group they're not a
designated terror group it's been
disbanded or or whatever it is so look
you can't have your cake and eat it as
well M so when it comes to Muslims and
burning of the Quran you know it's
freedom of speech fre speech but anyways
they've been intellectually chewing
chewed so please Zan make sure you Che
it till next time brother and sisters
from myself and zishan goodbye and we'll
be bringing you more of these videos
inah if you have any other videos like
this send them to us so we can react to
them till next
time do you want to speak with
confidence like these amazing
personalities every single one of these
amazing speakers have taken the same
program with brother the Muhammad Arad
Muhammad Arad has helped develop allot
of us it's extremely beneficial to do
this course definitely recommend this
course to access the free life-changing
training
now